If you're like me, you use a lot of
different applications all at the same
time, and they're usually scattered as
little icons at the bottom of the screen
or on your dock. But in Mac OS, we can
show all of the current running
applications on our desktop and be able
to quickly move from one to the other.
We refer to this as mission control.
This spreads everything out on your
desktop so that you can see everything
that you're currently using and quickly
move from one to the other. To be able
to use mission control, you can swipe
upwards with three fingers on your
trackpad or use the control up arrow
option. From here, you can create
multiple desktops, each one that might
have a different set of applications
running inside of it. We refer to this
multiple desktop capability as spaces.
And the spaces are available from within
the mission control screen. To use
mission control, we hold down the
control key and hit the up arrow. And
you can see all of the different
applications that are currently running
on my system. If you want to move to a
different application, you simply click
on that particular app and it will move
you directly to that application. You
can, of course, perform the same thing
again to move back to where you started.
When you do launch mission control,
you'll notice across the top is a
desktop one and a desktop 2. And you can
add additional desktops to this
configuration. This means that you could
build out separate desktops, each with
different applications, and be able to
quickly move from one desktop to the
other by simply choosing the desktop
options at the top of the
screen. When you're using a browser or
other applications within Mac OS, it
gives you the option to save that
password to be able to retrieve it
later. Mac OS stores all of these
passwords securely using an application
called Keychain. Keychain not only
stores your application, it can also
store your notes, certificates, and
anything else that may be sensitive
information. Keychain is not something
you add on to Mac OS, it's a feature
that is integrated into the Mac OS
operating system. Mac OS encrypts all of
this information that is stored in the
keychain. And the only way to decrypt
and access that information is by using
your login password.
An important feature of most operating
systems is a way to search the operating
system to find exactly the information
you need. In Mac OS, we refer to this
search as spotlight. This allows us to
find apps, documents, images, and
anything else that might be important in
our operating system. To use Spotlight,
you can click the magnifying glass
that's in the upper right of your
desktop, or you can press command space
and type in what you're looking for. It
will then go through your entire
operating system to find anything that
matches the information you added to the
search. If there's certain information
that you would rather Mac OS not look
through, you can always enable or
disable different categories of
information from within your system
preferences under the spotlight
category. So, if you use command space
and you type in Professor Messer, it
will search through folders, find
information that's in apps, identify
suggested websites, look through the
iTunes store, and much
more. The cloud-based service that
integrates and stores information across
multiple Apple operating systems is
iCloud. iCloud allows you to share
information across multiple devices,
including calendar settings, emails,
images, and much more. iCloud also has a
builtin backup process so you can have
information that is saved to iCloud the
moment you store it on your system. You
can manage your iCloud storage under
your system preferences in the iCloud
category. And with iCloud Drive, you can
store files in the cloud very similar to
Google Drive or Dropbox. This also takes
information from your applications and
stores it into your iCloud Drive as
well. This makes it very easy to store
information that you've created on a Mac
OS desktop and be able to access that
same data on an iPhone or an iPad.
iCloud is also a great way to
synchronize your data across all of
these different systems. For example,
the messages that you have on your
mobile phone, your iPad, and Mac OS can
all be integrated together through one
single iCloud account. You can also
customize exactly what type of
information is stored in iCloud by
enabling and disabling it under the
iCloud category of your system
preferences. For example, you can choose
to synchronize message information
between devices. You can make sure that
all of your FaceTime information is kept
up to date regardless of what Apple
device you're using. You might want to
store files in your iCloud drive and be
able to integrate those with the apps
that you use on all of these systems. Or
you might want to customize the
information that's stored in your iCloud
drive so that you can share all of this
data across multiple apps regardless of
what platform you're using. You can
scroll through this extensive list of
applications and data options within
your system preferences under the iCloud
category. You might be using a trackpad
in your Apple laptop or your iPad or you
might have an external trackpad that you
use on your Apple desktop. You can
customize how this trackpad operates
using the gestures feature within the
trackpad settings. You can customize
exactly what your trackpad will do if
you swipe, pinch, or click on the
trackpad itself. You can modify how to
access any of these features or you can
simply enable and disable those features
from the trackpad
options. In Windows, we have file
explorer and in Mac OS we have the
finder. Finder is a centralized file
management frontend that allows us to
launch applications, modify the file
names that we're using or delete the
files from our system. This also
integrates into a number of different
features that are built into the
operating system. For example, you can
see all of the file sharing options that
are along the left side and you can not
only connect to local drives, but also
drives that are located across the
network. This also shows you all of the
remote storage options on your network.
And if there are any devices that we're
able to remote control using screen
sharing, you'll see those appear in the
finder as
well. If you want to access information
quickly in Mac OS, you can simply scroll
down to the bottom of the screen and use
the built-in dock. This is a fast way to
access applications and data files that
you've stored in different areas of your
operating system. This is a way to have
quick access to your mostused
applications and you can easily see what
applications are currently in use. For
example, if you look at my doc, you may
notice that there are some icons that
have dots underneath the icon and those
dots indicate that that application is
currently being used. You might also
keep entire folders in the doc. That
way, you can access files very quickly
by simply going down to the doc and
clicking on that particular folder
instead of going into the finder. This
doc can also be customized by having it
hide itself automatically or you can
change where it's located on the screen
or move it to a different
display. These days, it's common to walk
around with multiple devices that you
would use, including your laptop, a
tablet, and perhaps a smartphone. With
Mac OS, iPad OS, and iOS, you can
integrate all of these devices together
using continuity. Continuity allows you
to begin working on one device and then
easily move to another device and pick
up where you left off. For example, you
could be browsing the internet on your
iPhone, then sit down at your desktop,
open up a browser, and it will show you
the page that you were last on when you
were using your smartphone. This goes
even a step further where you can use
hardware resources on a separate device
and apply those towards the computer
that you're currently using. For
example, you can use your iPhone as a
webcam when you're working on your Mac
desktop. Or you could be working on your
Mac OS desktop and then open a new
window to interact and view the
information that's on your iPhone. This
also forwards text messages between
devices and allows you to easily airdrop
files from one device to another. This
is a feature that is built into iCloud,
so if you're logged into iCloud through
all of your devices, you're able to use
continuity. If you're working with
drives, storage, or anything to do with
saving information on a Mac OS system,
then you need to become very familiar
with disk utility. Disutility is a
management frontend for all of your file
systems on all of your devices. Disk
Utility is a way to manage all of the
storage devices that are connected to
your Mac OS machine. If you simply need
to view and manage the configuration of
those devices, you can see it in disk
utility. You can also modify the
configuration of these file systems,
create new partitions, format drives,
and be able to manage any aspect of your
storage. You can also create images
within disk utility. So, you could take
an entire directory or everything that's
on a drive, create an image file of that
drive, and then transfer that image
drive to a third
party. In Windows, you might be familiar
with the full disk encryption
capabilities that are provided by Bit
Locker. In Mac OS, we have a similar
feature known as file vault. This
provides full disk encryption for the
entire operating system and it encrypts
everything using your local password or
it integrates into your iCloud
authentication. This means that any of
the data that you store in your drive is
protected and if somebody does gain
access to your physical storage drive,
they would not have access to the data
unless they also had these
authentication credentials. If you want
to turn on or turn off the file vault
capabilities of your Mac OS operating
system, you can find those options
inside of your system preferences under
privacy and
security. As a system administrator,
you're probably very familiar with
working at the command line and
understand the importance of being able
to manage a system from this terminal
screen. In Mac OS, you would use the
terminal app to gain access to the
command line. From here, you can view
information in your file system. You can
run shell scripts or you can modify
configuration settings for your
applications. In a future video, you'll
learn a number of different commands
that you can use inside of the Mac OS
terminal. Unfortunately, not every
application we use is going to operate
the way we might expect 100% of the
time. There might be cases where we need
to administratively stop an application
from running, especially an application
that seems to have hung up or is not
accessible from the normal user
interface. One way that you can stop
that application from executing is by
using the force quit option within Mac
OS. A common way to use force quit is to
use the keystroke command option escape.
It will bring up a window that shows all
of the applications that are currently
running. You can highlight any one of
those and then choose the option to
force quit. You can also force quit
directly from the doc. So you can view
the applications that are running in the
doc, hold down your option key, right
mouse click on the icon, and it will
give you the option to force quit that
app. So if you find that your operating
system is not working the way you would
expect, and you believe the problem is
associated with a single application,
you may want to force quit that
application and see if you can regain
control of your operating system.